I don't know just mute on a scar or
right on the chat and then we can read
at the end but I'm a little bit afraid
since we have another hazard physicist
in the crowd so maybe Valentina will
call [ __ ] of anything that I say so
let's see so yes so this talk it's kind
of I hope that everyone can read the
slides and you can see I mean I know
that there is the background but yeah
long story short I am sharing the whole
desktop but I hope that you can read so
this talk is kind of a mix between
previous talks that I had and I tried to
put them together it's kind of like
story experience Python physics talk and
I tried to remove most of the scary
parts
I just left one there just for you to to
get more more close to the topic in
general so M so this talk is mainly
about the experience that I have doing
astrophysics there may PhD it's was
mainly doing playing around with stars
black holes and of course Python if you
have any question of course you can find
me there later or you can write on the
chat so um I study computer science and
I started studying in 2006 and situation
back there at least for me was that I
was really into scripting I was doing
anything with Perl
- and Python was still something that at
least in my universe he was not really
widely used one of the nice thing is I
remember reading when 91 points zero was
out and it was like cool so some
something about erase and stuff but I
didn't even carry much so well the
jurors were advancing in 2009 M Python 3
was already out but of course we zero
and still at least in my university they
were like you know Perl people over the
place writing complicated lines and
other people that we started to look
into parallel computing but of course
we're having a C background and back
then I remember that I went to a
conference that was the authors of MPI
for PI and PI
good we're giving some talks and I was
like hmm so apparently you can use this
Python thingy in a more professional way
and maybe at the end of this year or in
the middle of these years there was also
this kind of I don't want to call it
fight but dispute between the angle and
Ruby on Rails because of you know
everyone wanted to do the scripting
things and web applications and so
Python was at least in my world was
starting to become more popular so when
I started my studies at the PhD more or
less I mean hi Python was still not a
thing around my the people that I had in
the uni not books with no and I remember
I was just an i Python because it was
kind of nice to have told a history of
the commands that you were using but in
any case pandas was like what no I think
that it was Oh point something I don't
remember the diversion of Candice and
this friend of mine that was doing some
forecast simulations who told me like oh
there's a new thing called scikit-learn
and it was like yeah well whatever I
mean pandas I could learn yet another
Python module that will not become
popular right so in this situation it
was like kind of really against I want
to say
completely against but like Python was
maybe some toy to play around with but
in any case is something that I really
like I mean it was really simple and
other people were really clean into
understanding what it was going on so
okay I had some experience I was
teaching some Python basic but okay so
maybe I can use this so when I started
to start I decided to start astrophysics
and just a disclaimer when people talk
about strana me serving is natural
science in general sometimes people also
referred to astronomy with observational
astronomy so people go into telescopes
or maybe manipulating some radio
telescope just just antennas and when we
are talking about astrophysics is
something that is inside astronomy um
and we you can't kind of like we're
studying
the nature of all these celestial
objects there and even if it even though
it's called as a physics it's used a lot
of chemistry too so that's kind of like
the the main difference of astronomy
NASA physics if you have a question that
is on the screen at the moment I think
that I will literally jump out of the
window astrology has nothing to do which
is field
it's a pseudoscience so let's go why
astrophysics to be honest I mean I when
I was finishing I was really into high
performance computing and I got really
tied into programming GPUs by then I
were using CUDA maybe most of you have
heard and now you can like write one
line and suddenly you have your machine
learning models on the GPU and but there
they was really cool because see
extensions you were handling memory by
hand and I don't know I was really in to
see so it was a really cool things to do
but most importantly there was this talk
since I have the desk of my way I will
just show it so there was a media was
showing some stuff there at some point
and they show these simulations I hope
that you were following it it looks
really cool right I mean I know when I
saw this thing in a conference in video
conference and I was like oh my god how
couldn't do that I want to do that
so this thing was skull and body problem
and then I started to read about it so
after reading and everything okay I was
I fact all my things I write here in
Germany and I was I was expecting from
you know a Research Institute widely
know with research that stuff from my
computer science background it was like
a so they would have some perfect
control systems software with
documentation there's implementation
details I was kind of like willing to
use all the tools and secure weapons
that I had for for my studies right I
mean robust frameworks using the latest
programming languages that helped me a
surface is doing stuff and of course
mainly science so what I found when I
arrived there and of course this is
really specific to my Center but after
talking with many
always kind of like same scenario but
back in 2012
so people with sharing code with the zip
files or tarji sets and until today one
of the most important people with this
embody problem that I show you is that
they have their own website doesn't
matter if you cannot read but and they
have all the versions there so this is
version control as astrophysicist and
okay so for anivia well can don't let us
compile some stuff and there were no
documentation or whatsoever I mean some
comments were like iron I remember still
some comments like we are using 3/4 here
because it's impairing empirically it
works but we don't have a reason for it
and stuff like that all of our
simulation coder was using scientific
papers of course implementation details
or documentation on how to use it you
know this nice like QuickStart stuff it
was completely missing but there were
many scientific papers that were high
highlighting the mathematical models
behind so you can get on a general idea
there was no frameworks lianas and this
programming language dominating
astrophysics at least in my Center was
Fortran there were some people rave
enough to do stuff in bash to automate
stuff and I met a couple of people they
were playing around with Python but they
were just not using it if you're not
familiar with Fortran first of all you
are really lucky but if not I just want
to share so for example here you have
some Fortran code if you are not
familiar with it it's really painful it
is for me too to read it and it's a
language that even though is fast and
whatever it's really not kind of like
approachable but there was science so
that was cool so ok so I was mentioning
before the embody problem and I wanted
to work and this is starting so there
will be some math now ahead but don't
worry about it I will try to explain
everything there so the important
problem is that mainly solving this
equation there that you see which maybe
could seem for you a little bit hard
just believe me it's not you will see a
prototype afterwards it's 300 years old
and this comes from Newton this is
Newtonian physics so this is nothing
else let the interaction of - what is
there you have R which is just distance
or the vector distance and you have here
acceleration two dots is because it's
derived twice so you'll derive a
position then you have a velocity and
the acceleration and usually this is the
description of or the physics behind
things are called
stellar systems or maybe you heard about
globular clusters or maybe you saw some
nice pictures that the one on the on the
right like many stars together so this
is a globular cluster okay so I started
to read a little bit about and then they
were like many different approaches to
solve this simple equation they were
like things called three code there was
like kind of like divide and conquer in
a hierarchical whale there was really
crazy extrapolation methods like the fmm
there was multiple methods and there was
a more naive approach that is just
applying the same formula that you saw
it is called Derek summation so I
thought okay if I want to start let's go
for the Oh N squared so first of all
reading all these scientific papers and
stuff was kind of complicated so I
needed something by hand that kind of
like was easy to write easy to
understand easy to derive and try to
play around with it so I decided to use
Python for everything that I was
prototyping and as you can see the
formula on the right the left
it's nothing else that the formula on
the right I mean of course inside
formula calculation you have some
subtractions and maybe some
multiplication you have some structure
storing everything but this mainly it
means nothing else besides this so okay
simple enough so I decided it's okay I
will so stick with Python and try to use
it with many other approaches so I
started to use it mainly for information
stuff usually the systems the one this
all these starts together there are like
many theoretical things that you will
write about like how to generate the
initial conditions and I was using one
of these primers
but again just a formula that you get
random points and then you have this
kind of the same the same instructor so
in the meantime meantime I just want to
highlight that I mean when you say
astrophysics usually maybe what comes to
your mind is like I don't know people
doing real science like for example this
photo or like people doing real things
like in labs and stuff that's
experimental astrophysics so what is
theoretical astrophysics is more or less
what we are all doing now sitting behind
a desk on a computer running some you
know some simulations and stuff so so
far is really simple approach so in
theory everyone here can kind of start
playing around with these things but of
course all the simulations are quite
demanding and you need to have like
access to giant clusters with hundreds
of nodes and stuff so another thing that
I did it was kind of generating you know
initial conditions and also all this
this is kind of an example of a
submission script so it's just a batch
script how to submit this to the class
the local class or I used to have so
many things start to repeat here like
for example okay I went 16 nodes I have
here 16 - so all these things were
automated and I had some magical script
that was generating these for a range of
course or number of particles for this
set of stars something else of course
was data processing and since I was
really beginning with the Python I was
relying mostly on the OS model you know
at least beer and everything but leaf
was still another thing when I was
unpacking binary structures I was using
this truck model that I don't know if
many of you know it if you want to
handle binary data and the fancier thing
that I learned it was like if you were
using Nampa load Tex was kind of slower
compared to the gen from Tex oh I I was
the Python expert because knowing that
but then you got yeah but if you're
working with data and stuff what about
pandas back there I was like I think
that oh one 2012 so it's not silly thing
and even though many people start to use
it I was not really into trying new
stuff because of course I needed to
finish experience and everything
so of course other really important
aspect is after you process all your
those data you can have nice combination
for a scientific paper like using
multiple leave in lattice and you can
have you know just random plots
therefore like following Latics style so
in this case for example this is how the
system evolves and scale with different
amount of particles using
openmp this uses I think it is MPI and
is using multiple GPUs and different
systems so you can see they're scaling
this is the number of party so stuff
like this was kind of like kind of like
an everyday thing so pythons started to
become my go-to tool to automate stuff I
was even at home phone automating email
sending because there were some
conference we were gonna hang there were
some some times that I needed to send
information inside I was even using
relying on Python to write small scripts
to send emails for example I don't know
if you know that you can configure maybe
your email or pop3 server and then just
write mail - s whatever and just write
an email from the command line but
sadler that was easily to automate but
so far is like yeah okay is that good so
meeting a couple of things and your life
was easy and stuff but it's kind of
boring so far so this was one of the
most entertaining thing that I started
to use I didn't know anything about
OpenGL and I started to write a data
visualization tool from all these embody
simulations as you can see there it was
one of the first prototypes the tool
then later on I rewrote it in C++ but
originally I was running this with PI
OpenGL and it was really straightforward
to kind of ended up having this
visualization which also looks really
nice I mean if I show you all the plots
but if you show you this it was all cool
some stars and points and there was also
some really things that I started to use
that map taught me a lot and I started
to do many and custom plots so in this
case it's a simple plot I started to
make some color for some specific of the
starts this is again the same thing more
or less that we are looking at here and
there is a phenomena that I wanted to
study at some point it's like the
the red dots maybe you don't see the red
but the dark colored stars here they
tend to use go to the middle of the
system in an in a phenomena that is
called core collapse so I did this with
map to live and then I had some
animation at some point that I couldn't
find him
and then I had like you know after a
couple of time step I can easily see all
the darker things there so I was really
hugging in too much but leave there are
many things that they were not possible
to do so and I guess that was the idea
that many other frameworks started to
born from what believe paddy I mean the
the belief scripts that I had was really
but it was really cool because nobody
else was able to do these they're using
new plot and stuff but it was really
complicated and not portable and I don't
know if I started to feel like Python
was really like my element like main
weapon for solving anything that any
problem that I had to render sighs so
that was a part of stars so regarding
all the black hole part of the story and
black holes are still a mystery and
maybe you remember from media some news
about it but still we have no nothing
and think about your article surfaces
astrophysics is that we write papers we
have stuff and maybe in couple maybe in
tens maybe hundreds of here someone will
say um no you were wrong this was the
original but so far we have no idea what
is inside black holes that's why we
still call it a black hole but maybe
there is some interesting particle
inside so I just usually I interact a
lot with people ab c--'s we don't we
cannot interact much I just wanted to
see if some of you knew this photo I
will expect maybe some hands on the
audience but in any case this is like oh
so this is an experimental facility that
has these really long arms and they were
sending laser beams to each arm at the
same time so imagine something like
coming from here and then from there and
then there were some mirrors at the
extreme and the thing was coming back
and what they were measuring
was that when the laser came back did
they were at the same time and we are
talking about here of like precision of
10 to the minus 20 something meters so
it's really really something really
crazy small maybe this is not familiar
with you but maybe they were
gravitational wave it's more familiar to
you
a couple of years ago there was a novel
prize and physics was a gravitational
ways so what they detect was a simple
gravitational wave that was coming from
the collision between two blocks so when
two massive objects in the universe like
black holes or neutron star maybe heard
about Newton stars collide they are so
massive that they freeze so much energy
that they disrupt space-time so this
means like you can imagine this simply
like imagine a lake and you throw a
stone and then you see all these ripples
going around it is the same but with
space them so what what does this means
if I am receiving a gravitational wave
then my my head will start to elongate
and then to the sides like an effect
like a spring effect but of course this
effect this elongation is something as
you can see maybe here numbers ten to
the minus twenty something meters so
it's something really really small so
you really need precise so so hey like
of course is located here on earth but
there are many other projects that are
coming in the future and one of this I
just wanted to highlight it this this
one here down
I don't here that I want to show you a
video about it it's called Lisa so the
laser is a laser interferometer space so
I know you have no sound but just
imagine really like inception most music
going on like you know but the idea of
this is grabbing the same let me just
pause here briefly is grabbing the same
idea that we have here on earth but on
space so they were want to go crazy and
launch the space rocket and once the
space work it is
up they will start to you know release
all these different satellites and in
all these satellites if you see there
they are like 23 they have been some
modification of these projects but they
will be around the space they will start
to communicate between them and they
will start to see ok so where do we need
to connect and then shooting lasers the
I know this sounds like Star Wars stuff
but it's not believe me and then they
have these self regularly things
millions of kilometers between the
lasers they will start receive
everything and I said ok sure we acquire
the signal and then we'll have the fixed
configuration that we will need to
maintain and these three satellites will
start to nothing else that go around
earth and start to observe everything
that we have around so the same thing
that we manage you can see there there
is a following Earth orbit I just want
to return that posit I will see to see
like many many many many more like a
little species and corners in the
universe that the project that I will
briefly describing before can so this is
a mission that is already accepted is
for 2030 for yes this space missions
takes time but it's something that will
be really amazing and maybe you will
remember this talk and in a couple of
years will say oh my god this was the
thing that was in PI data but I am
probably that one that mission is out
physics will change completely so also
another really interesting think about
black holes that use all this event
horizon telescope and pictures that you
can see there that's it's a picture tube
a cobalt what we see there all the
brightness is just photons are trapped
into the day event horizon of course of
the black hole and if you're interested
in these there was a real sci-fi talk
last year really interesting talk live
by Sarah is on so maybe you can go there
and see there it's called in the shadow
of battle really interesting stuff I
really invite you to go there but yeah
so let's go back a little bit back to
reality so what I was doing with black
holes was like you we know Newtonian
physics so the physics that you
learn maybe in high school or university
if you did something similar things
moving around orbits and as you can see
this animated gif you have heard that
it's kind of a little bit faster when
you go to the sound and slower this is
what's called Newtonian physics
everything was calculated here on earth
but as soon as we started to see things
outside earth we start to breathe and
descend that maybe we were wrong so have
you heard about mercury of course a
planet I don't know if any one of you
know any particular thing about mercury
even of course this is the first planet
of our solar system called Sun but did
you know that the orbit of mercury is
processing so you start here and then
it's kind of like tilting little by
little and then we have this kind of
like rose shape so nobody knew why this
was happening until of course there were
some more research and people who start
to understand that this was a new
physics so this was post-newtonian
physics I for this thing you have a set
of formulas that you can apply and in
the case of if you have like two stars
whirling around or black holes or
whatever just two things
whirling around you can get some effects
like this one for example you see the
two different lines are two different
objects in this case the lines resemble
the black hole that is really close to
merge with another one because they will
go wearing around and it will go
together and together and together at
some point would they will merge and I
will generate this gravitational wave
that I was mentioning so you can model
these things there are some formulas
that you can get are approximations to
this but how do we really calculate
these things and for this I just want to
all to take a deep breath because we
will see some weird things on the screen
now okay so we start from this point
this is Newtonian physics this is the
same equation that I show you before but
written in a different way
the procession that we know over mercury
it comes from the first post Antonio
therms there is another term the second
that is called e energy and there's the
third that is related to all the spins
of stars so how do you calculate first
post to another this is equation we have
speed of light there many different
fractions everything ok this is the
second the second was so complicated and
difficult to understand that you need a
correction so they amended to point five
which is a correction to the other one
and then you go to spin you have formula
like this and I'm sorry but it's not
complete so you need the second part of
the formula so it's really and then you
have the correction of that spin so and
then again there was not the whole
formula so these formulas will real
thing and I needed to work with it for
me at least it's impossible to start
debugging something inside a huge
framework so I needed something easy to
do it so that's why I decided to go with
pipe and all these systems relied on the
energy conservation so this is just
acceleration of particles but if you
want to go to energy you need to be
consistent and also consider these
things into the energy likely for that
the equations were not really big but
still there is a lot of things going on
there I don't expect you to even kind of
like try to read these things so this is
real I mean I use this in simulation if
the animation that you saw before this
kind of rose like I implemented it and
you can see here this is the final
implementation in C++ they have posted
onion terms 1 2 3 and since I was
working with the integration system that
was working with the derivative of the
acceleration I ended up having these
things again I don't expect you and I
don't wish you to ever leave back these
things do is this thing in C++ as this
was really complicated for me so I
needed to use Python and without Python
I think that I would be unable to even
understand if this thing was working or
not so it was real life server because
even complex form like this you can
writing in a simple way and trying
you understand so yeah that's enough for
maybe a couple of simulations but it's
this a real scenario I mean when we see
the skies or the news we see really nice
pictures out there and all these nice
pictures that showed colors that comes
from complex solutions so in this case I
was also using an existing piece of
software written in C called gadget and
this was a smooth particle hydrodynamics
code sounds really complicated but
you're a nutshell is let's have your
moving points and put some gas on it and
some fluid dynamics inside assistance so
I was referring to these pictures and
you can see here this is a really nice
simulation of two galaxies colliding the
simulation of this animation is based on
smooth particle iron dynamics so in that
case all the things that you see around
these bright spots is gas because gas
feed starts and then stars can go grow a
growing girl and even black holes can
even get larger by eating stars but how
do black to eat stars this is something
that also was really mind-blowing for me
we don't know we assume we have
different approaches to understand this
there are different things color for
example rocha love that it's kind of
like some celestial mechanics
calculations that you can can at least
eight or infinite symbol that it depends
of how massive the optics are there are
some people that really don't care much
about this okay I will define a radius
on this black hole and everything that
enters it will be swallowed by the the
black hole and there are other
approaches that say eh everything that
is bound to the black hole so this means
that the energy is interactive strongly
with it it will be created I created is
the world for eating of course we don't
use eating in papers so there was a lot
of again different scenarios in
configuration how to play around with a
gas
but still I was generating static pots
so these are some pictures of many
simulations that I run the simulation
took months they're all these orange
jell-o I don't know how good is your
screen are just gas particles and these
are millions of best particles we ran
around so since I was using this
software I would do this I really needed
to have something more visual and then
with Python I was able to make something
more nice which is of course an
animation so here you can see two black
holes rotating in the middle and then I
started to do this really cool
experience that was drawing gas clouds
to the black the binary all these the
bright spots that you are sitting on the
screen are areas where new stars can be
born so in simulations like this you can
see if I have two black holes I will
start generating stars you can see also
let me pause this you can see also some
maybe here you can see some struck oh my
god sorry this one you can see some
instructors around the black hole too so
for example there you can see some dense
areas around it so there are so many
applications here that when we ended up
having these simulations that we didn't
know where to start and we ended up like
having two papers and like ideas for all
the like four papers but we we notice
all these things because of this
animations made with Python of course
some people were looking at the plots
but usually plots were not about the
whole evolution and all simulation we
will look in specifically of these
animations made with Python and it was
really helpful to understand so this is
another another simulation that I just
want to just show you that things are
kind of different in this case the
clouds are being thrown in a
counterclockwise sorry in clockwise
while the black holes are
counterclockwise so you see some kind of
ring there that is being formed this is
really cool in
a nice ring that I was really happy
about it but it gets destroyed now when
this new cloud and see no ring anymore
so there was many conclusions that of
course I don't want to go into details
but structures were not really stables
in dissimilar but I am there are many
things there and a thing that I still
have multiple clouds if you are really
interesting to see more movies about
these things if you go to multiple
clouds that XY set I have all the videos
there are the simulations if you're
interested you can go there so when I
started working with these things most
of these things were little scripts
people that knew people that were
writing Python scripts that do something
reading the snapshots of some program
generating these nice animation and so
on and so forth another use of Python
back then was people wrapping around see
libraries that we saw before MPI stuff a
CUDA and there were people that wanted
to go forward and it was a really nice
project spending and I just recently
check it and it's really really a
willable at the moment it's called Muse
so we can use there go and Muse code to
get a value so this kind of glue of many
Astra physical pieces of code in one
place you can interact with different
simulations that are doing many stuff
and even to my surprise last year bike
on earth listen to many people doing
different thing with CUDA and GPU
computing that I thought it was only by
CUDA but now there was coop I Jax Rapids
there are so many no new things at the
moment that I think of this an area's
really prominent and helpful at the
moment but this was before right so what
do we have now I think that what num
focus is doing in general is for me is
the second boost of Python what we
needed in general I mean scientists over
the world now I think that they can
easily start setting up Jupiter
analytics and maybe you know using
pandas numpy whatever if you are more
into simulations with more DeCarlo
Markov chain things or maybe analytical
mathematics that
things that you can do with proprietary
software like mat lab and stuff you can
still do it would Python of course
there's also a SERP ID there is a
project that when I heard about last
year I look at it and it was delightful
to read there is a lot of tutorials and
documentation and I will have loved to
have that thing before I started
studying so I really believe that if we
know that the first rise of Python was a
well secondly the first one of course
their release but the angle kind of like
position Python out there then them
focus and science in general is kind of
positioning Python again as a de-facto
solution I'm really curious to see in
the next year like what is the next step
so some people is saying that maybe
Mobile is the future of Python
maybe webassembly maybe I don't know
writing Python and running everywhere
and just first four pi microcontrollers
or whatever but really cares about so
yeah I mean that's it I really hope that
it was not too boring or too deep or
maybe too brief for your taste but I
would be more than happy to answer some
questions now if you have some other
questions that you don't want to ask now
you can reach me there and Twitter or
whatever at the moment I am NOT doing
science but that's I think it's topic
for another talk but yeah I think that I
will be gladly to see like if there are
some questions or something Thanks let's
say ok so a new question I guess no
questions I guess so well I tried to
minimize all the formulas and stuff but
in any case my information was there so
any person with some questions can write
me thank you I would you mentioned a lot
like using Python I probably would have
yeah well the problem is that when I I
had a detail but I started to remove
slides because it was
mostly Python code and I was not sure if
there was but yeah maybe
what is that you ended up using just
pretty much like as you said numpy and
just a basic Python stuff and everything
else from scratch lost your voice why
did you I amuse myself just to hear you
and then I couldn't unmute me so yeah
and everything that I was using there
was numpy at the ends of my studies I
started to work with Python also with
pandas and it was like oh [ __ ] so why
didn't try this before but I yeah mainly
all the computational stuff was numpy by
CUDA I did some pie and there was not
pie in c3 but it was another Monte Carlo
Markov chain module to do some multicam
stuff yeah awesome I guess we don't have
questions I would I'm going to allow
people to unmute now and stop recording